today's guest is an Arctic biologist who
has come down directly from the great
white north to let us know exactly
what's going on and to answer some
questions we have about well all sorts
of stuff we're gonna get into nature
we're gonna get into the depths of the
cold and Alaska
today's guest is mr. Seth Boudreau
[Music]
[Music]
so do you just come from Alaska right
now coming from Costa Rica back up to
Alaska I just went down to see my lady
and spent some time in my place kind of
in the middle of the work season okay so
basically five months a year in Alaska
May through September studying migratory
birds and wildlife and then the rest of
the year I'm down in Costa Rica and yeah
because you sent me a picture from Cote
you sent me a picture one time of lunch
I guess it was and it was some guano
claws you guys had a batch of want
iguana yeah yeah yeah and I was like
dang bro yeah my lady's dead traps them
in the yard and cooks them up and it's
not that great yeah yeah if you're in if
you're in a tight spot someone's going
I'll get you through well yeah I saw it
looked uh when I looked at him and we'll
have Nick put the picture up too but it
they looked I'd have thought you two
eaten a different party to go on I'd
never really considered really the claw
yeah it was kind of all chopped up in
there but they're mostly bone so it
probably looked like a puff full of
claws yeah that's what it looked like
yeah
when you uh when you cook them up how do
you even cook those here yeah I think
you cook them in a pressure cooker with
like a chopped tomato and some garlic
and onion maybe some chicken bullion
pretty simple it's just kind of you can
cook it the same way you cook chicken
yeah but it's like it's not that great
is it like an island treat kinda is it
pretty common there in Costa Rica no I
think a lot of rural people eat it
occasionally but a lot of people think
it's gross and definitely don't eat it
too but oh yeah it's kind of interesting
like it's almost like when I was growing
up people would eat a lot of like
hogshead cheese and stuff and um you
know where my sister lived they cook
cracklins a lot of times we will just
you know take a bunch of fat and put in
a pot in here that's the best yeah at
the beginning you're like where's the
meat you know and then by the hand
you're just like left for these pieces
of fried leather oh and they're like
yeah and they're just hurting tasty
really hairy they're almost just it's
almost like they're almost like cotton
can't like the inverse of cotton candy
oh yeah pretty far on the other end of
the spectrum
sous-sous so when you go up to when you
go to Alaska what part of Alaska are you
in in the Arctic zone north of the
Brooks Range I'm at a science station
can you pull that up Nick the Brooks
Range so we could see that I just want
to have an idea where you are
yeah about 370 miles north of Fairbanks
yeah and I don't even know where
Fairbanks is Phoenix looks like this you
know these are the Aleutian Islands okay
thanks kind of right in the middle I
know I'm up towards the top there okay
yeah so I'm above north of that mountain
range oh wow so that's called the North
Slope up there that's where there's a
lot of oil business going on and the
Arctic National Wildlife Refuge
so which one you're you are up there
yeah it's about a 10 hour drive to get
up to where I work and if you go off the
top say you get to the top of Alaska and
you take a boat north what do you hit uh
North Pole eventually some ice really
yeah you can you can't really access the
coast there without paying for a permit
from the oil company to go on a tour you
can go on like an hour long tour where
you get to dip your toes in the Arctic
Ocean but they don't want people messing
around up there so you can't just access
it on your own they kind of own the
whole North coastline there so they say
well it's private property yeah yeah
there's a town called Deadhorse up there
it's not really much of a talents like
an industrial outpost where everything's
made of metal and there's just
testosterone in the air yeah it's a
rough place it's ugly but you can see
some cool birds up there spectacled
eiders and phalaropes and king eiders
and stuff it's pretty cool now are those
birds that are indeed there they're only
there spectacled eiders yeah a real
Arctic specialists they didn't even
really know where they spent the winter
until pretty recently the whole
population goes to like an opening and
the ice out in the Bering Sea I think
how you say it specks it's a lighter
cold Eider yeah I dar
and when you're up there like how close
you get into these birds like what do
you do to close my job I'm a naturalist
for this science station up there and so
every day I'm out there just trying to
document what's happening with wildlife
when the bird species arrived to the
area when they leave in the fall and
then other wildlife you know there's
bears and wolves and Wolverines and
stuff up there so I'm just out there
spending time trying to see what's going
on and document it just for posterity
basically oh wow yeah yeah so it's a sea
duck and they just breed on the coast
and grassy ponds and then spend the
winter out among the sea ice and
openings can you get a picture of the
fate of the head again ooh look at that
thing Wow yeah well and so what is that
coming off the back it almost looks like
gills up there by its head what is that
just feathering just yeah just weird
feathers and can you have one of these
at the house or these more these are
these you got to get some special
permits for that
yeah they don't they don't take kindly
it's I think it's a threatened species
probably there's just not that many of
them and they breathe in really specific
areas and can you watch them fight or
they don't fight what do they do or they
seem pretty docile to me they're just
kind of sitting around on the water
minding their own business yes
you know Arctic summer is really short
and so the birds kind of have to get
there and get on with it get the
breathing done and then get the hell out
of there so and that's what a lot of new
breeding is in the is in the summer yeah
pretty much only then so we have like a
hundred and ten species of birds we've
observed in the area that are coming
from the lower 48 states Central America
South America even all the way down to
Antarctica somewhat on the winter down
there
so birds kind of just come like
everybody's kind of popping in yeah yeah
who's kind of the Randy you know cuz
sometimes you're like on a plane to
Vegas and you got different groups you
got a couple of German guys you know you
got one guy making his own cocaine in
the backseat you know you got a bunch of
Italians
just just you know drinking deca 200
guys really what kind of group gets up
there and just really just turns it out
there's a bird called the blue throat
that is mostly a Eurasian bird and the
population just barely extends over into
Alaska so you have if you want to see
him in the United States you have to go
up there and they yeah look at that
they sing bird karaoke they do like
imitations of other bird species and
they'll do this repertoire that goes on
for they can imitate up to like 25
species of other birds but you eat so
you hear it you hear them singing all
this stuff but it sounds a little off
like karaoke where you're like I don't
think that's really the white-crowned
sparrow and it's that guy ah
and so they're just kind of there like
impersonators yeah yeah totally and the
other females seem to get a kick out of
the male with the biggest repertoire and
uh oh wow cool huh yeah that's cool it's
a bird there's like gonna be like I'm
gonna go up there and now can they will
they tempt other females from other
species to come on over with since
they're using different peoples song I
haven't seen them tempt females but
other species will definitely get
agitated if they hear another bird
singing their song because they one bird
sing they're basically advertising their
territory so they sing on the edges of
the territory and then and the bird with
the next territory over will hear it and
he'll kind of establish his border so
they suddenly hear their own song in a
place where they thought they had their
territory staked out someone definitely
respond aggressively so it's so when a
bird like sings it's it's always to let
people know that this is my territory
that and I'm available so they're
singing to let the females know that
they've got this pad and they're ready
to roll okay yeah so I got a comfortable
place here I got a little spot of Days
Inn or whatever got me a little spot
Hampton Inn got it for the summer yeah
okay so this is the only two reasons if
you hear a bird they're letting somebody
know about their territory mm-hmm or
they are letting females know that
they're available yeah pretty much yeah
and Diouf is it just male birds that
sing or female birds also say mostly
just male birds
and females do little calls that they
used to keep in touch with each other
and to warn each other predators and
stuff yeah yeah waiting for this one
[ __ ] to text me back right now it's
only been two weeks so she's probably
busy you know traveling or something
yeah um
how cool so when you get up to Alaska
man how cold is it like because people
think of Alaska and you know like a lot
of people you think of like gold country
and you and that sort of thing you think
of it being cold is there a level where
it doesn't matter that's cold anymore
that you can even like we can't even
really feel a difference between say you
know 20 degrees below and like 80
degrees below 20 degrees below is not
bad at all when you get down to 40 I
think 50 below is the lowest I've
experienced then you're just in pain you
just don't want to be outside at all and
yeah
so down to minus 20 it's very dry up
there at least in Fairbanks and so you
can still go skiing and stuff and have
an alright time but when it gets cold in
that like you can feel a breeze coming
underneath the bottom of your cabin door
just because the temperature difference
is so great that the air is just like
blowing in trying to equal it out so we
explained that to me like saying exactly
when there's differences in temperature
the air wind is basically air moving
from one place to another right okay a
ridiculously simple way to describe when
yeah I get it I think we all understand
that but like when there's a big
difference inside and outside the air is
trying to equalize to normal it out okay
so you have these like 10 inch thick
walls of a cabin or even the doors are
usually have several inches of
insulation but just at the bottom the
only space where there's a little bit of
air it's just blowing in like your pants
will go like this in the wind if you're
standing near the door because the air
is coming in it's so much colder outside
than it is inside if you have it you
know 60 inside that it just creates wind
just trying to rush that close to each
other
but when I get up there and early May
and that's when it's still winter a
little bit there's usually a few feet of
snow on the ground but it's already full
daylight so I don't see the sunset until
September so the sun's up the whole time
when you get there from men yep yeah
which yeah as I get older it gets harder
to be used to that like we have blackout
curtains you know to try to make it dark
in my room and stuff but it's you can't
keep it out the light a little bit so so
yeah it's it's kind of still winter a
little bit in early May and that's when
the birds start to arrive to the area so
I'm out there all day like just visiting
the same types of habitat and trying to
keep track of when each species arrives
to the area ok concierge almost yeah
just trying to help them get settled in
so you do that for years and years and
years and then you have a nice record of
exactly what was happening you know in
any given year and you can track changes
over time and that's kind of how the
good kinds of science work where you're
just
there's people studying really specific
stuff up there about carbon releasing in
the atmosphere and all that but I'm just
studying very basic like what are the
animals doing well I really love that
because I've just always been more of a
generalist but I like being outside and
just paying attention to stuff rather
than have my nose in the tundra sniffing
gases or whatever they're doing yeah
yeah yeah it's not you know there's much
of a corporate hunter right yeah yeah
when freelance yeah when they when when
you start to see like different patterns
from birds like is there a time when you
like really start to get scared like is
there one species that you really start
to pay attention to yeah there's there's
a couple times the birds have frightened
me a little bit there's a bird called a
long-tailed Jaeger mm-hmm that um it's a
sea bird basically it's kind of like a
ghoulish tarnish type of bird but
they're a predatory sea bird and they
only come in land to breed on tundra
yeah that one Wow so they eat voles and
lemmings and stuff
and when there aren't a lot of lemmings
or voles around those populations kind
of crash occasionally and when there's
not any round they'll just form groups
of like 40 and just maraud around and
one time I saw a group of 40 just coming
over a hill and it was kind of a
thundercloud in the distance and I was
like I didn't know that they did that
yet it's like why are these 40 Birds
coming here pretty gnarly yeah we
thought maybe they teamed up when we're
coming to get you we thought there was a
tsunami coming or something Wow yeah you
just you spend enough time out there you
see weird things like that most people
you know don't know happen yeah how I
mean annals are so in tune with Mother
Nature they're almost like um it's
almost like they're like working for
Mother Nature or something yeah
or like you could get clues from them
you know yeah yeah definitely I I
learned a lot about us from watching
them and I think that's one of the great
things about doing that kind of work is
just being out there and having the
opportunity to be away from all the
other noise that's going on and just
watch other things and have time to
think and yeah I've been doing it for 17
years now so like ever since I've been
an adult and is it a lifestyle that you
think you could get or that you would
want to go away from where do you start
to like look for I mean do you really
just look forward to that time up there
oh yeah I mean I'm away from my
girlfriend fiancee for those five months
which is why I go down and visit in the
middle of that for ten days so it's
really great to see here and that's a
cost you know like it's a definitely an
alternative lifestyle and a lot of
couples I don't think it'd pull it off
long-distance relationship but we've
been going nearly six years now and it's
all I love it you can't see it for four
months love you though for me it'd be
great yeah I mean it yeah it would just
be I think it's almost something I'm
gonna have to have in my life um I'm
trying to think of like was something
that I think about like how quiet does
it get it must give extremely quiet huh
it gets so quiet that you can hear your
own heartbeat like in your ears yeah
well there's no other sound especially
when there's no way
or anything and you don't yeah being
here I'm in the belly of the beast here
yeah especially la yeah oh my god flying
in everybody else seems to think it's
fine but I'm looking out there like this
is so wrong
now when you say that is it just like
the amount of people the amount of like
goings-on in one space like the lack of
space what
yeah the just humans living so out of
balance with nature and just everything
that's here we depend on someone else
somewhere else making and doing you know
like it's kind of weird yeah and I don't
think it's good for us really like
having watched animals for so long you
kind of realize like we are just another
animal we are an ape we're not special
we're not even domesticated like we're
as wild as we ever were we just have
changed our habitat a lot you know to
suit us but it comes at such a great
cost that when you're outside of this
stuff and have the peace and time to
kind of get out of it and then you come
back to it it's pretty shocking Wow yeah
but it's like you know if you're in a
bad relationship and your buddy could
come up and tell you why you should get
out of it
yeah you can listen and it makes logical
sense maybe but you come up with excuses
for why you're just not going to do it
yet and then years later when you do you
look back and like what the hell was I
thinking yeah that's going on yeah just
because I had that chance to be outside
of this human civilization kind of and
so you get a different perspective I
think but you but I can't expect to make
people understand that in the same way
that when you're in a better
relationship like someone could explain
something yeah yeah yeah it's hard to
see something when you're in it yeah so
it's nice to like down in Costa Rica you
know I'm living in a tiny little village
it's 200 people and there's no other
gringos around except for a couple of
families and Mennonites but oh yeah yeah
they're wild on their bacon over there
hit a little bakery and uh yeah they're
pretty interesting they call I got a
Facebook message from someone I didn't
know the other day saying the Mennonites
want you to call them Ganga and I'm like
what the Mennonites need me for yeah and
it was a bird identification quick I saw
a bird that wasn't in the book you know
like it's a Southern Man Thanksgiving
over there with those minnows man it's
beautiful and they're pretty
self-sufficient those cultures aren't
they like Mennonites and I'm Amish
in a way yeah the Mennonites are kind of
weird where they they use cell phones
they don't use the internet but they'll
use cell phones that use motors and not
like the Amish in that sense they're
really nice but you feel a little weird
around them because the women are
covered you know from head to toe and I
kissed
older Mennonite lady on the cheek by
accident cuz that's a custom in Costa
Rica when you say goodbye to someone
yeah yeah and as I got closer I kind of
realized like she doesn't want this to
happen but I'm into Todd yeah that's
most of a hug there are a lot of Jionni
and Nick sexual history yeah yeah all of
that going on in here but but yeah so
being in these quiet places that's great
when people visit like I've got a lot of
good buddies I grew up with who have
come down to the Costa Rica if you have
come up to Alaska but I don't get that
much time off up there so um yeah my 7
months a year off is down in Costa Rica
and that's where people come visit and
can kind of like I think they before
they visit they imagine me laying in a
hammock on the beach drinking Imperial
or something yeah yeah when they come
down and see we're living in like a
really small rural agricultural village
we're growing coffee you got to do a lot
of stuff as a lot of action yeah which
is that's kind of the best way we can be
is just doing work that's meaningful to
you to people around you yeah I can
imagine the exchange the human exchange
you get by helping others are being part
of a small community yeah yeah that's
how we're evolved to be you know like
we're supposed to be living in tribal
groups of you know up to a hundred 150
and then we we've gotten so far away
from that
I don't think we can see our way back
but do you think there could be a
correction that happens that brings us
back like sometimes I feel like that's
the thing that I'm wondering like this
mother nature finally like all right
enough of this Sims [ __ ] you know
yeah
about to tighten up the [ __ ] you know I
think it's unavoidable what happens to
every other species on earth every other
species population goes up and down and
up and down really yeah I mean like
links and snowshoe hares their
populations kind of follow each other as
the hare population gets high the links
start producing more kittens and then
start eating all the hares and start
dying off and then the Lynx have to die
off everything else goes like that and
if you look at a graph of the human
population since like 1700 we've just
gone in climate and we've done it by you
know like advances in agriculture and
medicine and everything which some of
them are great but we can't keep going
forever like yeah like how sustainable
is it it's not at all so that's hard to
watch happening like and that no one
gives a [ __ ] right now like I'm lucky
the time I've had to be out in the wild
and get that perspective but it makes it
harder to be in the civilized world
because no one else like knows what the
hell I'm talking about right oh yeah you
start to look like an alien
yeah it just seemed like something
that's it starts to seem like you're the
odd man out right exactly or when really
it's see it's kind of the other way I
mean I think especially in in America we
don't notice that there's more like
rural living in a lot of other cultures
yeah we don't realize that like and the
whole globe that there's tons of it
going oh yeah yeah like when people are
talking about how we're gonna have smart
cars driving everybody around here the
rest of the world has no idea that's
even being discussed right except for in
big cities maybe even like yeah it's
funny I go to Illinois like in the
summer and they have a small town up
there and they don't even get 4G like
its 3G is what you get on your phone so
it's like if you want to watch a video
dude you got to drive with your buddy
you know 19 minutes you know yeah and
park outside the McDonald's
that's enough fricking off phone heat so
it's like those people aren't even
worried about it's more like an
agricultural environment in that in that
area yeah everybody else looks down on
them you know yeah like they produce the
food we eat they do all this stuff that
we kind of tried to get away from having
to do ourselves yeah and then we look
down on them it's so wrong it is crazy I
mean especially like a lot of like media
and stuff these days yeah you know I
mean even Alaska I'm sure
I mean CNN hates anything that's white
it seems like so I'm surprised that they
even sir proposed on Alaska deniers but
um but yeah it is it I guess it's like I
mean you have such an interesting
insight into that because you get to see
what it's like you're almost living in
two different realms totally yeah yeah
and just occasionally passing through
this one and just being like what the
hell is going on because your layover
Zee here on the way on your way back to
write Costa Rica basically between these
two kind of remote areas I pass through
places like this and so I'm away for
long enough where things have changed
since I last came through and I can see
them and most of them are alarming Wow
like the uber drive over here is scarier
than any bear encounter I've ever had I
mean like it's way more dangerous being
on a highway here than being up there
and now dude you just you must notice so
many just like small like do you notice
that you are alarmed at a personal level
or do you notice that you are alarmed at
a NAT a level of like you know tension
in your body or things like that that
from being in the city like for on the
uber Drive for example yeah both for
sure like I definitely feel way more in
danger just because we're supposed to
know everybody that we interact with
that's how our brains have been for
hundreds of thousands of us so to be in
a place where I've got a couple buddies
I grew up with at a visit when I'm here
other than that everybody's a stranger
and yeah it it's kind of wild to think
of how many stranger you run across and
run past yeah so it's like people are
great generally but you just I think
evolu
generally in the back your mind you're
not at ease or at least I'm not you know
yeah
and and I think you know we're an eighth
but we're obviously super adaptable so
most people have adapted to deal with
that pretty fine and yeah not me do you
feel like we're definitely Apes you have
no doubt about it no doubt yeah anybody
who thinks for not just hasn't thought
about it enough I think but don't you
think man you got to think if we're
eight like I've never looked at an ape
like up for example I never been to the
zoo and been like you know miss the old
place you know like nowhere in my body
does that reflect and I'm not saying I
think maybe we might be monkeys that God
created you know like I think maybe do
you think we're really a tape like you
cuz have you ever smelled your armpit
like after a nice hike yeah a little bit
when I was younger yeah I mean I get the
hang of it now kind of but uh yeah I
mean like you watch how we behave in
groups and very much like Apes exactly
as Apes like it's a miracle anytime we
act above an ape I think it's a miracle
yeah and it doesn't happen that often
alaya the more that I always try to give
people the benefit of the doubt and then
I'll go around the different places and
I'm like damn it's really hard to keep
doing this yeah yeah you know people
like we we will constantly let each
other down yeah yeah it's terrible but
that's because there's so many of us so
crowded in that we don't mean anything
to each other like yeah that's of the
end that's a great stage yeah that's
exactly what I feel like here all the
time yeah you know when you're in a
small community where you're kind of
interdependent that's how we're
programmed to function like in a group
of apes non-human Apes or human Apes
like everybody's supposed to have a role
yeah and everybody kind of does
something that contributes to the group
every day
so in larger cities can have a lot of
people that they don't they may have a
role but they're it's not as prominent
or it's not as defined or maybe they
can't find their role there yeah
yeah we're so you probably didn't create
a lot of depression I would exactly yeah
so it's not surprising to me at all
how much depression there is and how
people are so disconnected
it's totally logical right you know
because we're in know I like thinking
about this is interesting yeah because
in cities it's so funny when I go home
or I go someplace else even when I go to
other places and in the u.s. even I just
feel somewhat the second I leave here I
feel so much more relaxed yeah yeah man
it just I just feel better yeah you know
I just feel like yeah I don't know I
just don't feel like I have to just I
feel like I have to fight so hard here
to just be a person yeah you know you do
and it's just taxing yeah after a while
it's real frenetic here there's no quiet
there's no darkness at night or there's
all the light pollution like it's so
against how we're how we spent so much
time being just in this recent fraction
of modern times is the only time we were
like this yeah yes it's so fast yeah
yeah what do you think are gonna be some
of the side effects of some of this that
we're gonna see I mean obviously we're
seeing a lot of now with like depression
you know you know people not feeling
like they fit into the world which makes
sense it's like how could you feel like
you fit in when there's so many people
all clogged together and our genetics
haven't really caught up to this this
new way of living yeah yeah I don't know
man
that's the thing is I have no answer for
it even after all this time it still
boggles my mind and I see no way out of
it other than just each person trying to
do good things where they can on a scale
that they can see the results of you
know yeah you know so like these we
always think of these problems as big
global issues but there are local issues
right just piled on top of each other
and they're all results of interval
individual people's decisions you know
yeah so like yeah that way all the time
yeah you can't solve a big global issue
you can just see work that needs to be
done do it and hope that you live to see
the results or that your kids do or
something but yeah even that we're
being an ape we're not programmed to
think that far possibly being here yeah
it's debate I mean it's just like here's
the thing dude I never seen an ape and
been like oh yeah you know really my
buddy you gotta you gotta go to the zoo
again man but why then over there man
over there but I never seen a navy had
not once if I looked at an ape men like
oh man yeah
wonder what the boys are up to [ __ ] no
man I'm not saying that it's not a
possibility but now what but but but uh
but you're out in nature you got in like
really you're out in the expanse of
probably some of the most beautiful
places you could probably see is that
true or is it just disgusting I know
barren up there and like is it miserable
uh it's both okay yeah like the
mosquitoes in Alaska in the summertime
on if you know but it's insane oh yeah
like you have a lot of racial slur he's
talking about the actual animal yeah you
have to wear head nets and stuff
really yeah yeah yeah but there's no
humidity right it's pretty dry but with
all the snowmelt that melts in the
spring and and the mosquitos have laid
their eggs in those areas and they kind
of start hatching out those videos that
have been shot up where I work where you
will not believe the amount of
mosquitoes so oh you got to go to
Jefferson Parish dude in Louisiana and
they have debt I mean we go toe to toe
with you yeah
where we bring our mosquitoes in you
bring yours yeah and we watch them
fighters over there Reena
and they hybridize yeah look at it wow
oh my god this look like a big orgy or
something yeah yeah but so like
intermittent but hold on a second
because this to thing everything in one
hour mosquitoes like little bitty birds
under there insects but are they similar
to birds or not they fly and some people
say it's the Alaska State bird you know
some bumper stickers okay that's
evidence right but as far as like
genetically and like are they similar
not really
No okay hmm kind of buzzkill a little
spicy no pun intended on the buzzkill
man that's good yeah and some I repeated
it cuz somewhere else are still didn't
get it
that's the only reason and I don't think
if I fully got it but that's a fair
point like there's great beauty up there
it's magnificent man that beauty make
you think like okay there's a higher
power there's something creating now I
mean yeah there's something there's
something bigger going on with something
creating all this yeah I don't know I
just with that question I always just
end up saying I don't know and I don't
know if it even matter it's like here we
are right right it's a good point yeah
like basing your whole existence on that
it seems kind of intense yeah I'm
thinking that you know which one of the
many thousands of answers is the right
one right but do you but when you when
you're in some of those spaces and it's
so natural and it's so quiet and you
have the ability to even hear your own
heartbeat yeah like it must be like
almost like a really intense meditation
that goes on at like a core level or at
like a level of even your your cells
that you can't even really fathom
probably a level of like peacefulness
and stuff yeah do you does that make you
feel like like what insight do you get
is there like something bigger going on
here or is there do you feel like a part
of something bigger or do you just feel
like really small does it you you
definitely feel more part of the big
picture but you also feel small bit
small because you are a tiny part of a
giant picture right now
so because especially if you're studying
nature and something like that you're
really I mean you're right there on the
food chain um you're basically yeah you
know and yeah I've been charged by the
people in the food chain really yeah
I've been charged by bears muskox I have
been sent with this one you know we tell
you how to end it with a swan I mean
I've had I've had I mean I've had a
couple I had some [ __ ] [ __ ] go off in
Oregon one time but you know I was
trying a jog and these
when some of those animals group up they
get real violent they do yeah it's like
an T fall most or something yeah you
know yeah yeah they definitely find
strength in numbers and UVU you really
you went toe-to-toe with the swan up
there I went hand and neck for this one
you killed it yeah yeah choked it out
damn boy that's what I'm saying do
Poirier over kabhi bro that's wrong
right they nearly got the best of me
though really they're like this tall
yeah and the wings are probably more
than six feet across
oh yeah and yeah Jesus yeah so the and
what do they do how do they come in like
what's their attack they're mostly
bodywork there have been so many dude I
remember they used to have this group in
a you know I used this term I don't know
loosely Rho however I use it but these
have a group that would come through our
College in town called it was [ __ ]
fistfights right and it was gay men that
would fistfight each other in a boxing
ring and you pay for it at the bar you
pay six dollars or something you got a
beer and you got to watch these guys go
at and uh but I would pay anything to
watch you know a a biologist and a and a
and a four and a half foot Swan figuring
things out go toe to toe yeah yeah
what's up so a lot of do they strike at
you what do they do they nip at you with
the beat yeah I got it by the neck right
away so it couldn't get me with the beak
but it was hissing at me
it wants to bet on this and the fact
that I went to the body first that's
always the best yeah yeah I was taken
aback but yeah so I had it by the neck
and it was beating me with its wings and
it's kind of disorienting it knows
that's a good term just raining so does
it feel like painful or does it feel
like scary kind of scary just because I
thought you know I had shot at once and
that was the last bullet we had where'd
you shoot it you just shoot at point
blank or how'd you shoot no it was in it
it was in the back uh Jesus Christ dude
like the coward of Jesse James have you
seen that movie man sorry to call you
out though but I know but dude we hadn't
we had
more food and we had another week to go
out there so what are you gonna do you
what are they oh the assassination of
Jesse James by the Coward Robert Ford
yeah I know I'm not proud of it was
trying to get away but uh so your food
was that vital at that point yeah I mean
we had this guy this pilot was supposed
to fly over drop off two dry bags full
of food and he was supposed to get a
hundred feet off the water but because
of the weather he was 500 feet upside
dry bags hit the water exploded Denzel
Washington right there
I've seen that so all we could salvage
we ran out into the river and trying to
grab what we could but it was going away
pretty quickly we got a small bottle of
whiskey that the pilot had included for
us just to be nice Wow and a couple of
fruit cups I and so and so that's your
that's your rations for the for what the
next week
it would have been yeah yeah a week and
a half I think so now you're like damn
yeah we're in trouble so and we were you
know probably a couple of hundred miles
outside of Fairbanks I think so there's
no getting out of there
and we're up a tiny little River where
you have to float all the way down to
get to a place where a plane a float
plane come get you and so yeah we just
had to start hunting grouse and geese
and ducks and whatever there was but we
had a limited we weren't planning on
hunting we have guns for bear protection
so we didn't have that many bullets you
know yeah so you had to ah did you guys
miss a couple times or you know no we're
pretty good and is it a pistol you
walking right up on him and shoot him in
the back or is he okay yeah Jesus man
yeah and we already met it makes me sad
a little yeah some grouse out there
chilling dude you know maybe having a
cigarette or just relax yeah yeah
thinking of my own and laying one day
there gross aren't that smart like yeah
I've hunted them before and they'll get
into a tree and they don't realize that
they don't blend in with the tree they
blend it in when they were on the ground
but then they're in a tree and you can
see like the
I think they think they still blend in
and they're like I see you they think
they're all slick looking at you yeah
now what about the Fox man we had a fox
in school when I was young and somebody
stole it right and I knew I knew it was
gonna happen but um but what about the
Fox are they out there yeah there's red
foxes up there the occasional arctic fox
and then you hear man they're cool to
see you watch them hunting voles through
the snow in the spring and they're
walking along on top of the snow and
then they'll [ __ ] their head and and
kind of triangulate the sound they're
hearing the vole moving under the snow
then they pop up in the air and dive
into the snow and probably six times out
of ten they come up with the vole it's
like evil Jima dude have you guys seen
that uh d-day or whatever that's insane
man is that one of the is that it one of
the most unique hunting techniques that
you see out definitely yeah yeah that's
one of the few species I've actually got
to see hunting even all this time up
there I've seen wolves chasing a caribou
once I look at that Fox and they're good
jumpers huh yeah people don't realize I
felt like the Greg Louganis of like the
animal kingdom so they hear the the
rodent under the snow yeah and then they
get that lift and just hit them yeah BAM
yeah they triangulate the location and
then I don't know how they do that math
in their head huh it's pretty wild now
what are some of the larger animals that
you'll see up there in the area that
you're in grizzly bears the occasional
moose musk ox caribou those are the big
ones which one is are the most friendly
do you find to like to humans or even
maybe overall do you or can animals do
someone can seem friendly like a dog can
seem real friendly yeah or any of those
larger animals you see up there
friendly caribou aren't unfriendly you
can trick them to come closer to you by
putting your arms up and it kind of
looks like a pair of antlers and either
they're eyesight's not that good or
they're not that bright but they'll
start walking towards you wondering if
they're gonna fight you or
try to copulate or yeah it's like a
drunk uncle almost I feel like soso care
but you can kind of get near yeah muskox
you can get in here they're pretty they
don't know what's going on they're just
eating vegetation and staying put pretty
much they don't move a lot
um do you get a sense of awe of a night
like do you get a sense of like what the
Ice Age was like and stuff when you're
up there like you start to get like a
sense of like wow what people have gone
through over history and stuff yeah yeah
you'll find not only fossils from 300
million years ago of coral and stuff
when it used to be under the ocean up
there yeah but then you'll also very
rarely find artifacts from native folks
from 10,000 years ago or whatever I
found a little spearhead sitting on top
of this little Knoll I went up there
because it was looked like a good
viewpoint and I'm sitting there looking
for animals and stuff and then I see
sitting next to me this spear points if
someone else thought it was a good
viewpoint also ten thousand years ago no
one else went up there since Wow yeah
that's crazy yeah so yeah it's amazing
knowing that it's a human something like
that is very human it like a yeah like a
I would feel so like wow like I'm a part
of something yeah
very long yeah and then you go back to
the station and eat ravioli you cut that
microwave shuts down those interview
cantata yeah I guess it's like it's hard
to not be stuck sometimes though in this
society that we're in that that's the
thing that you blame humans do you blame
businesses do you blame is there any
blame is it just the like where we are
kind of like and this isn't everyone
obviously this is more cities than rural
areas yeah I think it's the natural
tendency for most animals to try to make
their situation easier not necessarily
better or maybe in a certain definition
but easier like if a dog gets unlimited
food they'll might just eat themselves
into obesity right yeah
and it's not good for him but they might
if they could articulate their thoughts
it might be like well it's all this food
would be good if I ate it you know maybe
there won't be later so I think every
little incremental change along the way
has seemed like a benefit to us and it
has been in a sense but but they're
always unforeseen effects that come off
of it that you can't predict and by the
time they're really prevalent you're
already too far used to the thing that
you can't really think about going back
you know what I mean
uh yeah yeah if you get used to like
doing Halloween and they tell you no
you're gonna be a hugger you're still
gonna be a you lay on the porch forever
you know just expecting candy yeah yeah
yeah so that's the hardest thing it's
like I can totally see that and it's
really interesting because then even as
humans we have the addictive personality
yeah we have the ability the easy
ability to like that sugar lizard that
just gets with you know just grass the
easiest first thing yeah yeah I think
you really have to fight that instinct
these days in order to get to a more
natural state exactly yourself yeah and
most people aren't interested in that at
all like would never spend five minutes
even thinking about it right in that
baffling sometimes it is yeah because I
think a lot of times that we're all on
this struggle where we're trying to
we're trying we're trying our best you
know we know with it some of the stuff
you're saying we get it we can feel it
you know we know that I'm taking these
easy way outs here and there and I know
it's not benefiting me it like a level
inside of me but but then you see some
people and you're like oh they don't
they don't set a chance yeah not this
may be their next generation or two
might but whoever this person is he not
seeing some people wandering around a
gas station sometime like August dude
you know he'll stay in here forever dude
he's gonna eat one of those hot dogs
Yeah right he's gonna need 100 of them
all right you know this dude will be in
here forever yeah you know this dude
will lay on the grill after a while
he's gonna change his name to Frank yeah
just never in bro let's do the feed
himself to his own family like you know
I'm saying like it's just you meet
people that are alike and it's not their
fault really it's just maybe where they
are genetically yeah it's like oh
they're or it's the culture where
if everybody's doing this one thing it's
so hard to go against the grain and
that's that's the biggest part of the
trouble is that
millat of people say like what do you
want to go back to the 1700s no like
there were good things we gave up along
the way that we shouldn't have given up
like the great things we've come up with
in medicine like witchcraft I think yeah
I don't know I keep looking at these
guys they're not laughing at my jokes
either
I'm joking you're doing a good job
Jionni's not yes sure
get a real totalitarian environment but
so it is so isn't it crazy to think then
that like we're it's like survival of
what will be the fittest then moving
forward is it people that are able to
realize that that the firt like not to
give into all the comforts that are able
to have some awareness yeah or what is
the next survival of the fittest
survival of the fittest used to be it
was the strongest yeah right and it was
often sometimes the craftiest - yeah I
thought you had to also like you had to
align yourself with somebody that was
strength because you would need that
support but now I'm wondering what it's
becoming in our society in America
anyway yeah I feel like we're adapted to
get the next generation going but not
really anything beyond that which
logically we shouldn't be programmed to
think that far into the future because
every other animal just tries to get the
next generation out and then they've
done their that part you know forget
what the hell I was where I was going
with that
that's by having me in the middle of
every sentence imagine running in with a
room to tell people something they
forget what it was that's how I feel
every single sentence with a murder
weapon in your hand you're like [ __ ] man
I need a preposition you know it's a
little alarming what you guys got over
here Nick Jionni what's going on when
you're up in Alaska away from people
that long and then you come back do you
find it hard to come
indicate with people a little bit yeah I
think because I work alone most of the
time up there and I have my thoughts you
know on tumble dry up top yeah it can be
weird trying to articulate these kind of
ideas I guess but yeah people seem
stupid
that's a good question yeah do people
seems to when you come back to us like
when you come back to like you know know
like it's not stupid at all cuz you guys
are well adapted to your situation right
here you know like maybe not long term
as a species but everybody's just kind
of doing what they got to do you know in
LA is a short term environment it has it
must I feel like it screams that yeah
like people are here passing through to
get enough to get to the next whatever
they would rather be doing or an
environment that would be more
comfortable really a almost a for all
for the entire world this is almost
looks like an airport it feels like it
is yeah you know it even never ends it
feels like we're still in this like a
very far terminal the airport right yeah
we're podcast and even when I'm at my
apartment it feels like that I'm like
man I just never leave the airport yeah
you know it just never ends here what is
amazing about LA is how quickly you can
get way away from here like the hike I
went on yesterday with my buddy
up in the Sun Gabrielle mountains I
guess was it Eagle Rock or something it
was Dawson saddle up to soup peak I
think I am which is up at like nine
thousand seven hundred feet it's
gorgeous up there and we may be past ten
people on the trail and four or five
hours and you that was busy it was yeah
it's like this place is bumper-to-bumper
but you can get up to that peak and look
you can have a 360 view of everything
way out I don't know if it's Palmdale
where it's just flat desert out that way
I've been an Eagle Rock or something out
there before it was about an hour and 40
minute drive to get out there mm-hmm but
it's it was gorgeous was there a
chairlift that if you wanted to like it
was around there and then we asked some
chairlift
yeah
and yeah I think I've been up that hike
before is absolutely amazing yeah and
you can see LA and downtown and the
distance in the smog and it's just like
all of that is happening down there and
nobody's up here it's crazy huh yeah
some cool birds some dirty bird species
up there pygmy nuthatch really bushed it
oh dude I'll show you some [ __ ] bush
tits right over here off the 101
Williamson saps make seen some
definitely not on the work computers
though that's the rules we have going on
around here National Geographic oh dude
I remember jerking off back in the day
to National Geographic you know there's
a dark tip near a fire you know no
wonder I ended up like I did
that's a beautiful bird isn't it yeah
wow that's beautiful yeah do you think
um do you think like do you get a sense
when you're up there by their animals
that they know that you're a human do
they know like do they think that you're
like an anomaly or like a abnormality do
you think like it is kind of weird
because yeah they're not evolved to know
what we are I guess you know native
people have been there for 10,000 years
so maybe that's enough for some of them
most of them run away like they seem to
understand that whatever you are it's
probably not good yeah but I've had bird
but I've had Birds laying on my head you
know like oh that's cool yeah so there's
some animals that seem to see you as
like a some delaying on I guess do you
find that animals are still like curious
about like do you find that they're
curious a little bit like what are
animals like khana they're mostly just
minding their own business and trying
not to get eaten by something you know
like you ever watch a bird eating there
just looking up every two seconds like
they'll take a bite and then look up and
they just can't relax yeah so I don't
feel bad for him and the migration you
know like they migrate using a celestial
sky so they orient themselves to the
Stars and migrate that way real yeah
so they operate totally their migration
patterns they they basis all after
looking at the Stars and see what's
going on they they know where the North
Star is and
they orient based on that so they have
these kind of like tracks in their
genetics basically some of them have it
in there and some of them learn it but
that's it's sad because like all these
cities and all this light pollution
totally disorients them yeah you got a
couple of sparrows jerking off outside
of Detroit there's no reason yeah they
gotta move it along
but like but no I could totally imagine
that yeah like how we're damaging like
how we're like we don't even realize the
effects that were had not at all yeah
because most people never would have a
reason to stop and think about it like
the Twin Tower Memorial in New York they
have these two pillars of light that
they put up around that time I think in
late September and that's right during
bird migration and there's videos of
literally hundreds and thousands of
birds flying around and around and
around and falling to their death and if
they see a certain number of birds up
there in the lights they'll shut them
off for a half an hour but just that
alone is killing probably thousands of
birds a year so that's just that's the
kind of that's a perfect example you
have example like we're doing something
that we feel like humans are doing
something we feel like it's honoring
yeah you know others that it's you know
it's it's out of love and support you
know and then even in that space we're
killing on the ground we're just trying
to get to Florida yeah but that's the
thing yeah there's always unseen ample
yeah always unforeseen costs and I think
anytime you can ask yourself what is the
cost of what I'm doing or what I'm
participating in you find you you go
further down the line and you realize
things that you never would have figured
out from the get-go and that nobody
really talks about you know it's
interesting we think we try and think
about that even sometimes just here with
podcast like try not to sell like bad
products to be able or like that's great
you know we're trying like you know I'm
trying to think of what else yeah I mean
I think we're trying to affect the
things that are close to us but yeah
it's interesting it's like as you it's
so weird it's like you grow up or I grew
up anyway I guess like I'm
you end up in working in a business or
in society and it's kind of built where
it's like you want to you know achieve
things or achieve your goals and with
those you it's almost like you only
realize the side effects that are going
on or the even the chain that Europe
that were a part of the old system were
a part of isn't even it's not working
like very like copacetic with nature all
right because we don't have to see the
effects of anything we do now like
everything happens somewhere else
somebody else is doing everything to
produce the things we use and depend on
so back when we were in hunter-gatherer
groups we saw the effects of everything
you did right in front of you yeah you
couldn't eat everything there was
because then there was nothing left
right here we just kind of pretend that
there's an endless supply of everything
and we create so much destruction with
people like Jesus Christ and nature
Johnny yes Adam I mean it's almost does
it get sad a little bit it's totally sad
and that's that's one of the hardest
things is like feeling so at odds with
the rest of how most the society works
and kind of feeling like it really
shouldn't be like this
but you got to play the game a little
bit but right you have to play that way
you have to play the game some you have
to meet people where they are you have
to like do you look at society as like
is it hard not to look at societies like
oh were they're bad people
these people that we are bad it's hard
to not think that and that would just be
an emotional frustrated reaction you
know but I know everybody is in the
situation they're in and if I was in a
different situation I would be I would
have you know less freedom to make
choices - yeah unless time to think
about it so but that's why I like where
we live down south that small village
where everybody knows everybody and you
kind of help your neighbors out you
trade bananas and oranges and stuff yeah
teamwork yeah we grow coffee and we
drink our own coffee you know it's nice
to just when you can do something for
yourself do it
it hits this kind of instinctually
feeling we have where that was a part of
our genetics you know to be yeah yeah do
you feel like we're far from that if we
really tapped into it I don't know if we
are if we are already too far beyond
that or right like if we already become
too much of like you know zombies you
know I think so like I think every other
species gets knocked back down by
starvation predation or disease right
every single other thing and we keep
pushing those things off but we can't do
it forever
yeah so I'm talking about yeah I'm ready
for man I'm ready for yeah
like if I die and like a big you know
thing that's crazy it's like a you know
a war for food or something least it's
gonna be exciting yeah a good couple
hours to television you know
yeah it's getting somebody over you
filming it yes I'm filming it and even
if they're not what an exciting like
sometimes I think about that like
imagine being in like a real shootout or
a real like you know like you see a
Leonardo DiCaprio fight that bear in the
remanence or whatever yeah that was very
realistic yeah yeah and it's like how
great like even it's almost like just to
feel that alive for a minute yeah yeah
you know I was talking the other day to
this UFC fighter and he was telling me
like I seen a picture of me he lost a
fighter he'd come in second and and I
was like man but you still look like you
had like going through something and
he's like man it's crazy he's like every
fight you go through it's like you come
out even if you you don't get the
outcome you want mm-hmm he's like you
come out the other side there's a you
have new revelations about yourself like
at a level that you didn't even really
know yeah
and that down of stuff just man it's so
enviable then like sometimes just
beating this drum out here not that our
lives are bad or anything obviously you
know like you know it's it's comfortable
yeah sure yeah but is it as I often
wonder if I'm be and if I'm very much
rewarded at like a level inside of me
that is almost like a light that's
getting dimmer and dimmer over time
because we just keep throwing these like
blankets on it you know
I think you do good things you know for
the single moms and stuff like that oh
you you've definitely had an eye for
seeing things that you can do that are
good and do them right well that's nice
you to say that man you know and I'm
lucky I got it you know Nick and Johnny
really super you know we all kind of you
know Nick and I have similar backgrounds
and some of that and yeah but I think I
think even just hearing you say that
like you know touch the things that we
can that are close to us because I
noticed well I do notice that I don't
like about myself and I start saying out
we all need to be like this it's like
when that's when we get preachy and then
we just get disconnected yeah it's so
disconnecting it's like yeah if we're
gonna solve people always point at the
government like if we're good the
government just saw us yeah there are
people that and they're just humans like
if something's gonna be different we
have to make it we ever do it yeah it
reflects what we said we wanted
basically yeah so the problem is always
down at the individual level yeah but
it's kind of nice it falls back on us in
the end like totally if all these cities
burn or if there's an electric outage
out or outer edge and we're never able
to get it back up or something you know
like immediately you really quickly are
gonna be your your brain is he asking
yourself Who am I like quick-turn yeah
who are you you know can you do and what
can you do yeah you can't do anything
that's necessary I'm gonna Joe Rogan's
but hopefully dude that's probably I'll
be back there to skin and bison for him
yeah if if something does go down like
the power yeah you're right can you
imagine how quickly it would be complete
chaos yeah well nobody knows how to grow
anything nobody knows how to fix
anything the water suddenly doesn't come
to your apartment nobody knows how to
live like that yeah so it's not gonna be
good
and I'm not gonna survive it either like
I can grow some things but not enough to
but do you go [ __ ] bro let's be
honest do you could rear naked choke a
swamp
me and Nicky jihadi huh
so he's built pretty well do you can see
his ass in the movie MA you ever see
that movie it's a pretty decent movie
but uh yeah no reason in the middle the
movie they made Johnny goodnight I
actually have a question so I feel like
a lot of people all the time are like oh
well where do I start there's so much
like I feel like I'm so behind like
what's something that someone could
start doing like every day like somebody
could do something where they could
further themselves to help the
environment instead of just destroying
it I think the Amish like you wouldn't
want to live like the Amish right I
don't know dude I like not having a lot
of choices bro yeah limited choices dude
that's a great point yeah humans do best
when their choices are limited I think
that's great to hear actually and if you
have every new technology that comes out
the Amish asks themselves what is this
going to do to our community and they
usually come to a conclusion that they
shouldn't accept this new technology Wow
and we should do a lot more of that on
the individual level but I realize how
hard it is like I kept off from getting
a smartphone for a bunch of years longer
than most people but then I got one and
I spent too much time on it and we're
we're so easily falling into those holes
you know so if I don't need to spend
time outside like people need to get
away from light pollution and noise
pollution and just get to a quiet place
and sit there and think a little bit you
know like so many of our politicians and
stuff who are making big decisions that
affect everybody most of them have never
been to a wilderness area like they
don't even know what it is to be a human
animal they just know like what it is to
be living in modern society and think
that that's how everything has to be you
know yeah yeah and we and it's so funny
even hearing like it's making me think
like we think that's so much like even
just being in LA for a while you start
to think that everybody's similar you
that everybody's like you mom which
probably makes you have some desire to
be different which makes a lot of people
at
freakishly probably yeah I don't know
man maybe not maybe I mean you might be
right I couldn't I was listening to you
but I couldn't process what you were
saying okay and that's why my it's you
know sometimes this [ __ ] you know
sounds like offline man and that's it
there's nothing I can do it sometimes
I'm looking at stuff I don't really know
what's going on yeah you know but you
can also like but you know here's what I
was thinking out but it's not our fault
as humans it's like we're just humans
like right if you're just born into the
into an environment like it's nobody's
fault right yeah exactly so it's just
like I guess what type of and what type
of life do we want to know or what type
of yeah what can like what type of life
we want to live what do we want to know
you know what do we want to see is like
the capabilities in ourselves yeah some
cultures especially are very happy with
just like comfort and you know and then
I think there's some people or not
cultures but some people they just want
more they want something different yeah
when things are available it's hard to
deny yourself taking them you know and
so yeah ask the British dude you know
yeah so we get blamed for slavery but
they really did it but um but yeah it's
so true it's like when things and it's
like I wonder if that's just the story
of humans how we're supposed to be it's
like probably a - you know it's like
it's natural right what we're doing is
natural and even a bird you set a nice
little thing of bread over - you know -
branches from a bird that guy's gonna
[ __ ] be over there yeah yeah so once
birds get these little you know yeah
they get a smart beak [ __ ] wrap a
coyote ate my fiance's sandals the other
day and I was kind of sexy kind of
lethal I was kind of surprised that a
coyote had the spare time to be doing
that kind of stuff
yeah shouldn't they be out finding
somebody you don't tell me it's hitting
everybody yeah creature comforts man
you're gonna see a coyote insane yeah
it's interesting yeah so when do you go
back when you go back into uh into the
great white north you're so far up there
yeah you're so far up there
you're close to Asia yeah people even
realizing we get to the north of Alaska
you know you're almost you're pretty
much practically Japanese a little bit
yeah I've been to one of the Alaskan
islands where you can see Russia it's
like 35 miles away you need to see this
I see cliff mm-hmm and the native folks
said that they used to go back and forth
because the Siberian Yupik speak the
same language as the ones in the Alaska
side they used to trade ladies back and
forth and stuff and now they can anymore
and yeah so it's a crazy environment
it's mostly treeless up up that far
north it's north of the treeline so you
can see really great distances and yeah
it's incredible it comes alive in June
all the little plants start growing a
little bit and flowering the birds are
all breeding theirs are fattening up and
then by late August it starts snowing
again and everything dies and then
September it starts getting covered in
snow again that's you really it's really
life cycle you see a real life cycle
yeah I buried that condensed into a
short period of time Wow and yeah so I
once the migratory birds take off then I
basically follow them down to Costa Rica
and get there and see them passing
through so it's kind of a migratory
lifestyle you ever seen one of the same
birds yeah well I haven't seen one up
there and then seen the same individual
down there but I have seen birds return
that have gone on migration and come
back to the same exact places so because
I've done bird research in Costa Rica
and you bend them you put a little cut
like this you know the internet they put
a little sock or so yeah and so yeah we
had we studied golden-winged warblers
and they winter in Central America and
breed up in northern US and Canada so
they fly all the way they're navigating
by the stars and then past the breeding
season don't get eaten by anything
reproduce and fly all the way back to
the same patches of forest as and it's a
little 9 gram bird if you think it's
just like like coming home it's just
like humans do you think it's some of
that same type of thing like you want to
go home sometimes or the
or is it just more of like a like a
natural thing they just that like they
they have to go right back to the same
spot like is there a reason for it
they have territories so they'll come
back to the same spot and defend a
territory even on the wintering grounds
some of them pretty aggressively but do
they have gay birds do or not be honest
with me um yeah I mean Ducks especially
are oh yeah in a park all the time yeah
and penguins penguins are terrible if I
was a penguin I would be you're out
there tough life day yeah you show up to
shore and there's two million there you
playing it you know you're playing a
ruder than anybody that's freaking you
know willing at that point got a pulse
or not yeah yeah I worked in Antarctica
as well so I've I've done a lot the
North Pole really the Antarctic South
Pole yeah yeah I worked on a sail ship a
hundred year old Dutch tallship that
took people down to the Antarctic
Peninsula from Argentina and back and
and and once we did a trip all the way
over to South Africa from South America
the Antarctica visited Tristan da Cunha
which is the most remote inhabited
island in the whole world
Wow it's like 400 in bread people living
on this volcano in the middle of 400
people only six last names that's
beautiful yeah and what do they seem
like at a certain point are they do they
seem really like in tune with what's
going on are they just like five armed
and just you know hoping for the best
it's pretty weird
they weren't even on a monetary system
until 1960 so they were just bartering
and stuff and every family has like a
couple of sheep and a cow in a certain
size piece of land on the side of this
volcano they were nice people but you
could tell that after being there a
couple days they're kind of ready for
you to get out of Willy yeah could you
kind of what you look at the flow a
little bit yeah just maybe just because
like we're talking about you're supposed
to know everybody in your immediate
beer and then you have this ship sailing
up and a bunch of scruffy people from
Holland and stuff coming up and taking
pictures of everything
no no it's probably a little off-putting
yeah I could imagine I'd like to go over
there and we could do a group trip you
know do a work work trip yeah you have
to sail there or take a boat there like
there's no other way to get there cuz
it's too far for any and when you pull
up like what are these people doing I
mean they're all but I mean like you
said that it's very tribal huh it's not
really tribal like they're they're all
one group yeah yeah but they're it's not
native people that's the weird thing
they're all descended from sealers and
whalers who shipwrecked there and so
there's Italian descent English descent
they have this kind of weird British
accent it's really weird hmm and it's Co
chicks or not be honest I didn't see
anybody my last question for you are
this is my last thing I want to think
about everybody you know it's obviously
a big topic always global warming you
know like do you what are your thoughts
man do you feel like we are ruining
things do you feel like that it's just
the flow of things that you know that
there's a cycle like would it with some
of your vibe from being up there on on
some of the front lines of just seeing
what's happened yeah where I work
there's a lot of people studying climate
change and yeah it's very clear that
it's happening and of course it's
because of us
like at least to a certain extent like
the amount of people on the earth
burning things and using up resources
like there's no way that that wouldn't
affect things so but to me that's kind
of like it's a big concern but even if
we fix that we'd still not be really
getting anywhere as far as I'm concerned
and do you see like a lot of the people
that are up there doing research and
that kind of stuff do you trust all the
research that they're doing like
sometimes it just seems like I mean
people these days especially you can
create any any any belief you want and
I'm not denying climbing or anything
like that I'm saying like but you know
people can create anything they want
everybody has a technology to create any
story that they want to yeah do you see
some of that like some of it seems like
kind of motivated like in like negative
ways or do you feel like it's it's on
it's just research like people want to
know what's going on I think the
research is pretty honest trying to
document what's going on but you
definitely see people studying things
that they know they'll be able to get
funding for mmm yes yeah you almost have
to you have to plan ahead just want to
get the funding yeah because you yeah
even if your ideas to up to sometimes
though it could be more helpful yeah a
government agency so I'm not gonna get
the funding for that we're gonna sound
crazy to them yeah Wow but it's a yeah
it's a great place and there's up to 150
people there during the peak of the
summer there's only about three people
there during the winter most of the time
just three people living it and a little
bit of murder every now and then well no
there's never been any real that's the
thing is like I don't know we look back
at hunter-gatherer people are small
groups of people and think that it was
all violence all the time really wasn't
like it was occasional skirmishes when
they bring groups and stuff but like it
wasn't that bad it was high infant
mortality but if he made it through that
you generally lived a pretty normal life
span yeah babies die sister you got to
open fire going on oh yeah
babies are risky you know let them crawl
into it raising just to see what the
gods wanted yeah or just to let the
strong survive it's just different
obstacles Tony Robbins thing there's
different value systems you know that we
can't imagine taking part in but if we
were born there would think it's totally
normal right yeah you know it's an
almost almost almost feel like a little
bit not embarrassed I guess talking to
you a little bit but like I almost feel
a little ashamed of our own existence a
little bit not from you as a person but
just like thinking about that
you never think about it you know like
you never really I don't know or I don't
anyway a lot of people might and I wish
I did more and I think you actually
reached out to originally saying hey man
you should go on some hikes you should
cook I think it's how we kind of crossed
paths is that right yeah I called in
with a swan call oh that's right okay
because then I know we've communicated
or emailing you send me some very
beautiful pictures and we're gonna put
some of those up throughout the episode
and like just kind of filling me in like
every now then I'll get you know like
come on email just let me know what's
going on powerful over Guana me with
some crazy birds yeah I'm like okay and
I'll tell somebody next to me they don't
give a [ __ ] right yeah they do not care
but yeah yeah you shouldn't feel
embarrassed or anything like I know I
feel ashamed a little bit as a human
there's a little bit of that that starts
out yeah well that's good I think we
should all have a little bit of that
because we at the expense or what we
demand for our like standard of living
creates a lot of destruction so we
should be ashamed of it we should be
aware we should do some work to become
aware of our effects on the world
because just to be a good neighbor to
other things you know yeah that would be
nice but I know it sounds preachy and I
know that most people are just getting
up and having to work and don't have the
time to think about that stuff but it
sounds hopeful though also I think in a
little bit I think I don't think it
sounds preachy yeah I don't think you
sound preachy at all I think it sounds
like studied and hopeful you know I'm
not hopeful right oh maybe I want you to
be hum bro just what you flying to LAX
man like oh yeah I might ask you have
hope around here okay but no I look it's
like especially here like you know
everybody look I've people here look
down they have no empathy for like
people in other parts of like especially
America smaller jams where people are
like what do they do they're all they're
doing is like having a lot of trying to
have a good life you're loving more to
their neighbor yeah and not get
overwhelmed with things that don't kind
of make their spirit feel good yeah
they're more into you have more people
that can hunt more people that can grow
yeah I agree man I mean that kind of
stuff makes me furious yeah it's hard
when there's some parts of rural living
that aren't good you know like there's
the massive opioid addiction issues but
I think that stems from them being
dismissed by everybody else and oh yeah
indict almost like coal coming in and
taking all the money away and leaving
people sick and stuff yeah so it's not
surprising at all yeah it's not
surprising at all when people feel like
left out yeah and it's happening in the
village in Costa Rica too where
everybody's being raised to think if you
get out of this village you're a success
if you get a college degree it doesn't
matter what you end up doing or if you
never see your family again that's a
success and we kind of did that in this
country too yeah and people are
separated from their families and it's
happening down there and it's kind of
like I think some of that could change
though yeah I think some of that could
really say I hope so I believe that
because I think people are starting to
realize that there's just such a there's
such a with not certain parts of America
like LEDs to control like what would
happen in Hollywood in a nemedian that
sort of thing and it's it's going away
now so I think a lot of people who are
dreamers or we want to be creators I
think they I think a lot of you are
hopefully gonna start to want to build
up the places that they're from or the
places that they live because there's
such a bottleneck here it was such a
bottleneck in certain places that a lot
of the best creativity never gets to be
seen yeah even though if it were spread
out a little bit more it would really
flourish yeah
did you have any people believing really
wild things where you grew up like rural
superstitions oh yeah yeah we have a
woman we're friends with down in the
village who way denim Costa Rica yeah so
40 years ago when she was pregnant they
had an outhouse out that in the backyard
and she had to go to the bathroom at
night
and she didn't feel like yeah she's
something she didn't feel like walking
all the way to the outhouse so she just
went behind the house yeah man
when she looked down after she peed
there was a fer-de-lance pit viper
coiled up right there and she said it
didn't bite me and she always purposes
this kind of stuff with I know you're
not gonna believe me but it didn't bite
me because the urine of pregnant women
is electrified Wow so this she thinks a
snake was sitting there like just scared
no like that electrocuted I could see
that yeah I could see yeah oh yeah dude
if something hits on me that was
pregnancy I take the afternoon off
easily man yeah I'd probably enjoy the
warm rain sensation yeah oh man I mean
this really is Dark Arts as you can get
yeah do you have to come back and let us
know what it's what's going on out there
you know any warning signs you know of
like any real huge flare-ups but I
certainly appreciate you come and set
than just talking to us about you know
what it's like I by the north pole I'll
buy Alaska and like and they never built
a SAN or anything like that up there
right yeah actually south of Fairbanks
is a town called North Pole where they
have a giant Santa statue my sad little
reindeer and in a pin and you can go sit
on Santa's lap and stuff it's a little
dark artist yeah and they're also you
seem like they're trying to make a
statement with the reindeer in the pan
or they or no or is it just it's a real
reindeer it's real but it's not a real
good one it's looking pretty sad look
David there's like 30 reindeer left yeah
but that's you know when you see animals
in the zoo and they're walking in
circles and stuff I kind of draw a
parallel between that and human society
like they have food they have shelter so
in a sense you think they they're fine
right but why are they walking in
circles like seeing with us like we're
safe generally we've got food don't have
to worry about all that much why are
people so unhappy yeah because there's
something that tiger who walks around
the cage all day long is missing yeah
same for us I like that it's a good
thought man we got a break out of the
zoo yeah but we also have to yeah we
have to break out of the zoo we do have
to do it we got to get a food with us so
fun
took a stork out you know but yeah I
agree with you man
thanks for coming man and hanging out
thanks for really appreciate man it's
great oh it's great to to meet you in
person
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
little time for me to set that parking
brake
and let myself
[Music]
[Music]